Hugh Jackman's blue and yellow Wolverine
costume is sparking Twitter Buzz for the
upcoming Deadpool 3 but something's
missing and fans aren't holding back you
have questions originally shared by
Deadpool himself Ryan Reynolds by an
Instagram Story the image shows the Merc
with the mouth striding next to Logan
wearing a suit that looks very similar
to his classic look in the original
Comics something that many fans want to
see in the third installment of the
R-rated franchise and for the most part
fans seem to be responding positively to
Wolverine's more comics accurate
costuming a sticking point for more than
20 years now ever since he made his
live-action debut wearing black leather
and Brian singer's X-Men one pan posted
this angers me so much look how cool he
looks this just proves that Brian Singer
had absolutely no vision but if most
fans seem to be pleased seeing
Wolverine's classic colors in live
action there's also a key component of
his costume missing from the photo that
would be the distinctive pointed
headgear that he's worn in almost all of
his Comics incarnations but which has
never been seen in action in any of the
live action movies provoking Decades of
debate about how the X-Men should really
look after the new pick drop one Twitter
user summed up the feelings of many
X-Men fans posting it's great seeing
Hugh Jackman finally suited up as
Wolverine in the Classic X-Men suit but
it'll be pointless if he doesn't wear
the cowl Wolverine's mask with its tall
fins that mirror his double ax hairdo is
one of the most distinctive in all of
comics but it's not difficult to see why
it hasn't been used in any of the
characters live action appearances as
cool as it looks on the page it's tough
to imagine it not looking silly in live
action which has a completely different
set of aesthetic values for superhero
costumes but we seem to be moving in a
direction of more comics accurate
costumes with bright colors and fashion
flourishes that wouldn't have been an
option and a less superhero saturated
environment
thank you Kevin feige Love You Kevin
feige Deadpool 3 will likely be a
multiversal adventure with many
different versions of Wolverine and
other characters so it's likely we'll be
seeing Jackman in a variety of different
Wolverine costumes including hopefully
one with his signature mask even if it's
only used for a brief throwaway gag
Wolverine one Twitter user even has an
idea for one posting there needs to be a
running gag of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
constantly taking his Wolverine mask off
at the start of every scene like to the
point that he takes it off in one shot
and then suddenly he'll be wearing it
again in the next shot and he takes it
off again Etc there's another
consideration at work here Beyond just
the Aesthetics of Wolverine's cowl Finns
in real life versus when portrayed in
ink on the page it's no problem at all
to hide the hero's face behind a mask
and in fact it's standard practice in
the superhero genre watch enough
live-action superheroes including Hugh
Jackman is Wolverine and Ryan Reynolds
is Deadpool though and you'll see a lot
more face time than you usually get in
the comic book Source material Deadpool
3 will presumably continue this so even
if we do end up getting to see Jackman
wearing Wolverine's classic cowl and
probably won't be for very long another
burning question is whether a photo of
Jackman wearing the headgear will ever
make its way online Deadpool 3 drops on
May 3rd 2024 so Jackman Don's a cowl we
might be seeing it in an upcoming
trailer or a leaked set pick in the
coming months
foreign